WE ARE ALL ON BOARD TO SAY THE
LEAST.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
ALSO DEVELOPING TONIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
RELEASED MORE DETAILS ON THE
DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO
AS WE ARE ALSO WAITING FOR A
DECISION ON THE SPECIAL MASTER
TO REVIEW THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS.
HERE TO BREAK IT ALL DOWN,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTORS
GREGG JARRETT AND SARA CARTER.
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE ALL STILL
SURPRISING WE ARE HEADING INTO A
HOLIDAY WEEKEND, FASCINATINGLY
THIS IS WHERE JOE BIDEN DECIDES
TO DO IS WE LEAD INTO THIS AND
NOW HE'S TRYING TO WALK IT BACK
BUT THIS IS COUPLED WITH A
DECLINE OF HIS POPULARITY
ACCORDING TO REUTERS, BY SEVEN
POINTS.
AFTER THE MAR-A-LAGO READ, AFTER
THOSE SCHOOL LOAN DEBACLE, THE
PAYBACK PERIOD NOW YOU'VE GOT
THIS IMAGERY THAT WE'VE GOT IN
THIS FIGHT ABOUT THE SPECIAL
MASTER.
SO WE ARE GOING TO -- AS WE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING, THE JUDGE WANTS
TO WRITE OUT SOMETHING DECENT TO
EXPLAIN HER DECISION.
WHY IS THE DOJ FIGHTING THIS SO
BADLY WHEN IT WOULD HELP US ALL
RESPECT TO THE END RESULT OF
WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE ABOVE THE
LAW AND THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
FAIR OR NEUTRAL OR OBJECTIVE.
IT WAS INCREDIBLY END SADLY
APPROPRIATE, LAST NIGHT'S
IMAGERY IN FRONT OF INDEPENDENCE
HALL THAT WAS RIGHT OUT OF
DANTE'S INFERNO AND A HIERONYMUS
BOSCH PAINTING.
IT UNDERSCORES THAT THIS IS THAT
A PRESIDENT WHO IF YOU DARE TO
OPPOSE HIM, IF YOU DON'T LIKE
HIS POLICIES, INSTEAD LIKE
REPUBLICAN POLICIES WHERE YOU
VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP.
BASICALLY HALF OF AMERICA.
JOE BIDEN WILL USE THE FBI, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND SOON
THE IRS TO COME DOWN ON YOU LIKE
A TON OF BRICKS WITH THE FULL
FORCE OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT WE LEARNED IN TODAY'S
DISCLOSURE IS THEY TOOK
EVERYTHING FROM MAR-A-LAGO
EXCEPT THE CHANDELIERS AND THE
CARPETING.
TOOK HUNDREDS OF PERSONAL ITEMS,
NEWSPAPERS, BOOKS, CLOTHING FOR
GOODNESS' SAKES.
IT SIMPLY PROVES THAT THIS WAS A
LAWLESS SEARCH AND SEIZURE UNDER
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT BUT NONE OF
IT ADDRESSES THE REAL LEGAL
ISSUES.
THE SO-CALLED CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ACTUALLY DECLASSIFIED
AND NUMBER TWO, DID THE
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY HAVE, UNDER
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT, A
RIGHT OF ACCESS AND CUSTODY OF
THESE DOCUMENTS?
THAT'S NEVER BEEN LITIGATED
UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ACT.
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HANDLED IN A CIVIL ENFORCEMENT
PROCEEDING.
NOT THIS LAWLESS SEARCH AND
SEIZURE.
>> Tammy: SARAH, IT'S
INTERESTING, WHILE WE ARE
DISCUSSING -- IF WE CAN TRUST
THE FBI AND THEIR INTENTIONS AND
THE INTENTIONS OF THE GOVERNMENT
AND THE DIRECT, THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND THEIR
TEAMS.
AFTER THAT SPEECH LAST NIGHT, IS
THERE ANY DOUBT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS AN ENTITY IS A
PROBLEM?
>> I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU.
IT WAS LIKE THE LIFTING OF THE
VEIL.
THAT'S WHAT I TALKED ABOUT.
LOOKING AT THE SPEECH LAST NIGHT
IN SHEER, STUN HORROR AND THEN
THINKING TO MYSELF OH, LOOK,
HE'S ACTUALLY EXPOSING HIMSELF
AND HIS ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION.
THIS ENTIRE RAID INTO MAR-A-LAGO
IS OBVIOUSLY POLITICAL.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A CONTINUATION OF
WHAT STARTED WAY BACK IN 2016.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS GO BACK TO
2016 TO REALIZE EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY HOW THEY TARGETED
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND EVERYONE
AROUND HIM.
THE FBI USING THE STEELE DOSSIER
THAT WAS PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
ATTORNEYS IN ORDER TO SPY ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEN TO SPY
ON CARTER PAGE, A CITIZEN OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW THEY EXPANDED THEIR POWERS
AND HOW NOW JUST AS GREG IS
SAYING, THEY ARE EXPANDING THEIR
POWERS TO US, THE PEOPLE.
WE SAW THAT, IT WAS EVIDENT.
IF IT WALKS LIKE A DUCK AND IT
LOOKS LIKE A DUCK, IT'S USUALLY
A DUCK.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE SEEING WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND I
THINK EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW FAR
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND HOW FAR
THE RADICAL LEFT IS WILLING TO
GO BECAUSE WITH THE HIRING OF
87,000 IRS AGENTS IN AN FBI THAT
SEEMS BENT ON POLITICAL
WEAPONIZATION OF HIS AGENCY
AGAINST AN OPPONENT, POLITICAL
OPPONENT, OUR NATION IS NO
LONGER LIVING BY ITS FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES.
IT'S COMPLETELY LIVING BY
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Tammy: WE HAVE SEEN SOME
HINTS OF THIS WITH LOIS LERNER
AND THE IRS.
THE FBI AND OTHERS THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS FOR DECADES.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE JUST NOT
EVEN TRYING TO PRETEND WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BECOME
WITH THE AGENCIES, WITHOUT RIGHT
LEADERSHIP, REFORMATION, AS